Now it's time for a question. Based on
the discussion we've had thus far, what I would
like you to think about is, coming up
to the scorecard for the three different structures that
I have identified. One is the monolithic operating
system, the DOS-like structure, and the microkernel-based operating system.
And what I would like you to do
is think about the features that are important in
the structure of the operating system. Extensibility,
protection, performance. And try to fill out this
score card as to which of these features are adequately met by each one of
these structures. So for each of these
operating system structures, monolithic, think about whether it
meets all of the features that I've identified
here. Do the same thing for Dos-like structure.
Do the same thing for the microkernel based structure.